Let's have the solution for our PSHARE versus
GSHARE quiz. The question is, for all of
the branches in this code, how much history do we need to make them all very
well predicted? We have 1, 2, 3 branches. This
branch here is easily predictable even without any history. So for this one,
any history will work. The exit branch. We do 1,000
iteration, each time it's not taken except the
last time. So for this branch again we
don't need much history. Even with no history
using just a 2 bit counter we will predict
this branch accurately 1000 times followed by one
misprediction so it's a very good prediction rate still.
This branch however, requires some history. This is
the even-odd branch, so we really need to know
whether the previous outcome was even or odd, so
that we can do the opposite. For PShare, the
even-odd handling can be done with just a history
length of 1 and the history length of 1
will work well for these two as well. So we just need a history length of 1. For
GShare, when we are doing this branch, we want
its previous outcome to be part of the global history.
If we look at what the global history looks like, this branch is not
taken, so the global history will be 0. This branch in the very
first iteration, because i.e is 1000, that's divisible
by 2, is taken because the number is even. This branch is is
then taken. Then we have this branch 0. Now it's going to be
not taken here, followed by a taken here, and
this pattern will repeat. So really, we need this to
be part of the history when we're predicting this. We
need this to be part of the history when we're
predicting this and so on. In order to do
that, we need the history to contain at least this
much which is 3 bits. And similarly here we need
this to be our history, so it catches this bit.
Know that really, there are only 2 possible histories
for this branch. One is the 1, 1, 0 and
the other is 0, 1, 0 because the other
two branches are just having the same outcome every time,
so we need a 3-bit history. As you can
see, GShare can do a similar job to PShare except
that it needs a longer history. Even for branches that
are actually kind of self determining. Note that GShare can
also do those correlative branches that PShare cannot do.